welcome to what I believe to be
YouTube's only complete and totally free
Private Pilot ground course throughout
this series I will teach you everything
you need to know in order to earn your
wings as a
[Music]
pilot what's up guys I'm Josh and this
is my father-in-law Mike and this is
lesson one on my totally free Private
Pilot ground course today we're going to
be talking about the four forces that
act on an airplane while it's in flight
this is a super important lesson because
if you have a basic understanding of
aerodynamics this is going to give you a
good foundation that you can start
building on throughout your training
plus these questions might be on the
written test oh I didn't mention that
there's a written test oh yeah there's a
written test and you've got to pass it
with at least a 70% but don't worry I
got you anyway let's take a look at
these four forces that affect our
airplane in flight as you can see these
forces are lift weight thrust and drag
now the first Force you should know
about is lift as you can see this is the
upward force that actually picks the
aircraft up away from the ground and
this is caused by basically two things
relative wind and the wing design now we
Pilots have a super fancy name for this
Wing design we call it an air foil but I
don't want to go into too much detail on
that right now cuz we're going to be
talking about that in more detail in the
next lesson the next Force we need to
consider when flying an aircraft is
weight now weight is simply the combined
load of all the people on board the
aircraft all the fuel any baggage or
cargo you might have and even the
aircraft itself it includes everything
on board the aircraft the other thing
you should know about the weight is that
it opposes lift and acts downward
through the center of gravity now we'll
discuss the center of gravity more in an
upcoming episode but the center of
gravity is basically where the average
weight of the aircraft and everything on
board is centered if you could hang an
airplane from a string and you were to
place a center of gravity directly
beneath the string the aircraft would
balance perfectly now here's something
that may not make a lot of sense yet but
it's important to know in steady
unaccelerated flight lift and weight are
both equal but we'll come back to that
here in just a second next we have
thrust and this is the force that
propels our aircraft forward thrust is
typically created by some kind of engine
and propeller working together or a
rotor for helicopter nerds out there now
the important thing to know about thrust
is that in order to move the aircraft
forward you must first overcome drag
which we depict here as a rearward force
but really this Force just opposes
forward movement and that drag makes it
difficult to move the aircraft forward
and there are two types of drag that you
should be concerned about as a pilot
parasite drag and induced drag what
happens when you stick your hand out of
the window of a moving vehicle the wind
pulls your hand back doesn't it the
faster you drive Drive the more your
hand gets pulled back this is what we
call parasite drag and just like it does
when you stick your hand out of a moving
vehicle parasite drag increases as air
speed increases as you can see from this
chart it increases exponentially with
faster air speeds that's one of the
reasons why we can't fly super fast in
our training aircraft there's way too
much parasite drag holding the airplane
back at high air speeds now there are
actually three different types of
parasite drag and the first one is form
drag in a nutshell form drag is wind
that goes around the shape of the
aircraft how much form drag do you think
an aircraft of this shape would produce
probably a lot right it's not a smooth
round shape that can allow air to
smoothly flow around it another type of
parasite drag is interference drag this
one might be a little bit harder to
understand but this type of drag occurs
when different streams of air flow
create little pockets of turbulence at
different places on the aircraft and
this restricts the smooth air flow
around the surface of the aircraft next
we have skin friction drag this type of
Paras it drag is drag that's caused by
the surface of the aircraft if we were
able to zoom in with a microscope and
look at the skin of the aircraft what
you find is that it's actually not as
smooth as it looks wind can still act on
these little microscopically rough areas
and reduce the speed of our aircraft as
you might have noticed we typically
paint or polish the exterior surfaces of
an aircraft to reduce skin friction drag
but it's never completely eliminated
induced drag is the other type of drag
that affects our aircraft it's created
as a direct result of lift I'm going to
explain this more in the next episode
but our wings direct the relative wind
above and below the surface of the wing
and this creates lift but it also
creates induced drag now induced drag is
kind of weird as air speed increases the
wing gets more efficient and because of
that induc drag actually decreases
here's what's interesting if we were to
look at these two types of drag on a
chart what you find is that parasite
drag increases exponentially with air
speed but induc drag decreases
exponentially with air speed because of
that there's a magical little air speed
range on every aircraft where we can
achieve the least amount of drag
possible when we're out flying around
and a lot of air speeds you're going to
be flying are directly related to this
air speed Pilots often refer to this as
the lift to drag Ratio or LD Max you
might be wondering why it's called the
lift to drag ratio and not the thrust to
drag ratio well just like lift and
weight in steady unaccelerated flight
thrust and drag are both equal but all
these forces are directly related to
each other you're probably wondering why
the heck we're learning about aerody
Dynamics today you just want to get into
the plane and start flying but if you
understand this concept it's going to
help you understand how to control the
aircraft anytime I make an adjustment to
any one of these forces it's going to
cause a change in one of the other
forces now we said that during steady
unaccelerated flight lift and weight are
both equal now that I've got my airplane
trimmed out for for level flight let's
see what happens when I increase my air
speed by increasing my thrust all right
so I'm I've got the airplane all trimmed
out I'm at 1,600 ft uh somewhere around
85 knots watch what happens when I just
increase my thrust Just Watch What
Happens
here I don't have my hands on the
controls but notice the airplane
starting to
climb so thrust and weight are no longer
equal as you can see my wings Start
creating more lift when we accelerate
when I increase my thrust my lift
becomes greater than my weight and the
opposite is true when I decelerate okay
now I'm trimmed out for level un
accelerated flight again at this point
thrust and drag are equal but what
happens if I increase my lift watch my
air speed as I raise the nose of the
aircraft and I'm flying at 80 knots I'm
at 2,000
ft okay so watch my air speed when I
raise the nose of the air L up so I'm
increasing lift right now watch my air
speed yeah that's right the air speed is
bleeding off I made a change before I
increased my lift we were in steady
unaccelerated flight when I increased my
lift I also increase my induced drag and
this caused my drag to be stronger than
the thrust which slowed down my aircraft
understanding these basic principles is
probably the most important step to
learning how to control an airplane and
now that you've watched this video you
haven't understand understanding that
most Pilots don't get in their first
ground lesson if you want to continue
learning how to fly I recommend starting
the playlist where you'll be picking up
with lesson two and there you can binge
watch the series when you take a break
you can pick up right where you left off
thanks for watching see you
[Music]